-Performing his new song
"No Body,"
making his fourth appearance on
the same episode of our show,
the most appearance of anyone
tonight,
The one and only Blake Shelton,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Dixie cup martinis ♪
♪ Second one's a freebie ♪
♪ Happy Friday afternoon ♪
♪ That neon sun's rising ♪
♪ I'm sitting here admiring ♪
♪ The summer dress,
it's shining through ♪
♪ Had just enough to tell you
the truth ♪
♪ Don't wanna scoot the boots
with nobody ♪
♪ Get straight tequila drunk
on nobody ♪
♪ Wrap these arms
around nobody ♪
♪ No body, but yours ♪
♪ Don't wanna shadow dance
with nobody ♪
♪ Slide some cotton
off of nobody ♪
♪ Don't wanna wake up
kissing nobody ♪
♪ No body, but yours ♪
♪ Honeysuckle talking ♪
♪ Last call on me walking ♪
♪ Out there to a checkered cab ♪
♪ B-line to your condo ♪
♪ Conway on the stereo ♪
♪ Girl, I'd love to lay you
down, down, down ♪
♪ Don't wanna scoot the boots
with nobody ♪
♪ Get straight tequila drunk
on nobody ♪
♪ Wrap these arms
around nobody ♪
♪ No body, but yours ♪
♪ Don't wanna shadow dance
with nobody ♪
♪ Slide some cotton
off of nobody ♪
♪ Don't wanna wake up
kissing nobody ♪
♪ No body, but yours ♪
♪♪
♪ Don't wanna hold nobody ♪
♪ Lay eyes on nobody ♪
♪ Love up on nobody ♪
♪ Don't wanna scoot the boots
with nobody ♪
♪ Get straight tequila drunk
on nobody ♪
♪ Wrap these arms
around nobody, come on ♪
♪ No body, but yours ♪
♪ Don't wanna shadow dance
with nobody ♪
♪ Slide some cotton
off of nobody ♪
♪ Don't wanna wake up
kissing nobody ♪
♪ No body, but yours ♪
♪ Don't wanna wake up
kissing nobody ♪
♪ No body, but yours ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]